paul el supremo tribunal federal
investigará al árbol sonar la indagación
de la máxima corte judicial se debe a
las acusaciones que hizo el presidente
contra el sistema de votación
electrónica de brasil en una transmisión
en directo el 29 de julio bolsonaro
atacó al tribunal electoral
es justo que el que sacó a lula da silva
de la cárcel y lo hizo elegible sea el
mismo que cuenta los votos en el puerto
secreto del tribunal en el affaire grato
no te sea así
aportas a las elecciones presidenciales
y siguiendo la línea de trump en 2020
bolsonaro parece allanar el camino desde
ya para alegar un fraude electoral en la
contienda en la que aspiraría a ser
reelegido el mandatario alegó sin
pruebas que en 2018 sacó más votos de
los que realmente obtuvo y dijo que para
evitar un supuesto fraude en 2022 se
necesita un voto impreso auditable la
idea es que la máquina que usan los
brasileños hace 25 años para emitir su
voto electrónico imprima además el
sufragio y luego lo envié a una urna
cerrada para finalmente contar los votos
manualmente pero desde el tribunal
electoral responden que el supuesto
fraude es la excusa del autoritarismo
una de las vertientes del autoritarismo
contemporáneo es el discurso de que si
yo perdí hubo fraude porque no se acepta
que alguien distinto a mí pueda ganar
las elecciones
el tribunal enfatiza que nunca ha habido
fraude desde que se implementó el voto
electrónico en 1996 y que la verdadera
trampa estaría en hacer un reconteo
manual de 150 millones de votos de 500
mil urnas
fue además la propuesta de bolsonaro
costaría dos mil millones de reales que
son cerca de 389 millones de dólares
para que al final sea la misma máquina
del voto electrónico la que imprime la
valor